i also want to thank your predecessor
his excellency vulcan bosakir of turkey
for his leadership and guidance in truly
difficult times
and i congratulate his excellent
excellency antonio guterres on his
reappointment as usual secretary general
perhaps more than ever it is important
we continue to strengthen
multilateralism and international
rules-based order with the united
nations playing
a central role
you are right mr president in pointing
out how this moment in history calls for
above all hope
violence
poverty and hunger
are once again on the rise
our post-pandemic recovery will be even
more hard pressed in upending the
world's uneven economic development
devastating natural disasters especially
due to severe weather patterns
and increasingly more difficult to deal
with
and as our best scientific minds tell us
we can no longer afford to ignore
how climate change is making natural
hazards worse
migration continues to rise
further further fueling discontent in
its wake
all along
populists and disinformation campaigns
blatantly or maliciously ignoring
factual accounts
can unnervingly shake people's
confidence in public authorities
in science and in the media but we
cannot
and we must not and i hope we shall not
give in
it is our responsibility as global
leaders to tackle these false narratives
head on
to win back the people's trust and to
give them hope
multilateralism global solidarity and
international cooperation have little
if any alternatives
it is a sound way forward for rational
beings
the united nations stands only to
benefit from its cooperation with
regional multilateral actors
like in the european context the eu
the council of europe the osce
and nato
i therefore want to re-emphasize
croatia's commitment to our collective
efforts in tackling the many challenges
before us
this includes taking action on climate
change
our commitment to solidarity in times of
crisis
protecting human rights
and upholding international law
humanitarian law promoting education and
the empowerment of women
peaceful conflict resolution
fighting organized crime and corruption
countering terrorism and dealing with
disruptive technologies
mr president the covet 19 pandemic is a
historical or historic test for our
generation
how we respond today
both individually and collectively will
greatly shape the rules
generations to come
croatia is pleased to have been able to
coordinate with afghanistan the
resolution on the comprehensive and
coordinated response to the coronavirus
disease pandemic
which not only set a stage for our
recovery
but also for building back better
the resolution also recognizes the value
of an integrated one health approach
by better understanding the health
related interlinkages of humans animals
in our ecosystem we stand a better
chance at tackling
anti-microbial resistance as well as
preventing and containing another major
zoonotic disease outbreak
i think we all share in the aspirations
of a comprehensive
multi-sector engagement in strengthening
national regional and global capacities
as well as society's overall resilience
to future panamek
let us maintain momentum and keep
working towards a more robust
architecture
that will reinforce global health
security
the world health organization plays a
pile plays a pivotal role
and therefore
is further development and strengthening
is essential
establishing legal standards and
assuring compliance is a fundamental
part of an effective multilateral
cooperative response
this is why croatia actively advocates
the pandemic preparedness and response
agreement
as an upcoming member of ecosoc
for the term
2022-24
croatia wants to foster the deliverance
of a stronger multilateral response to
the pandemic
in the spirit of global solidarity and
partnership
safe and effective vaccines as well as
diagnostics and treatment
need to be made more easily accessible
to all
in a timely and sustainable way
and without discrimination on any of any
routes
we are firmly committed to supporting
the work of ecosoc
as the un's keep key platform
for implementing the 20-30 agenda for
sustainable development
clearing our path to recovery
mr president
ahead of the 26th u.n climate change
conference
in glasgow
this november it is vital we stay on
track and promote the continuous
implementation of the paris agreement
even pope francis
who has dedicated his first encyclical
laudato sea
the common heritage of our planet is
expected to attend
the necessary changes in our lives
and our economies
will certainly not be easy
however
i am convinced that shifting to green
and sustainable technologies
can go hand-in-hand with economic growth
croatia is actively setting up a
legislative and strategic framework
which is a prerequisite for coordinated
action on climate change
our commitments to reaching climate
neutrality is visible through several
key strategic documents
the national development strategy 2030
the strategy of low carbon development
2030 we reviewed to 2050 and the five
year action plan for the implementation
of a strategy of low carbon development
let me say a few words about our saudis
neighborhood
croatia has vested interests in the
well-being of the western balkans
the region's stability functionality
and prosperity
mean a great deal to us
this is why croatia is one of the
strongest advocates of the region's eu
enlargement prospects
the fulfillment of well-established
criteria the implementation of reforms
and delivering tangible results
remain key requirements
for your membership
but even more so the path to membership
serves to secure the higher standards
it's all people aspire to
democratic transformation and rule of
law will remain central markers
but we have also continued but we have
also continued to call on all regional
leaders to lower tensions
overcome their differences
and seek ways to build
lasting partnerships
in a way
bosnia and herzegovina is a cornerstone
of peace and security in the wider
region
its territorial integrity functioning
institutions
and it interacting cohabitation has
always been important concerns for
croatia
yet
the situation in bosnia
is as challenging and as complex as it
gets in the western balkans and it is
always challenging in the western
we would like to see a stable peaceful
and prosperous bosnian herzegovina
progressing firmly on the path to the eu
membership a country where the equality
amongst its three constituent peoples
and the rights of all its citizens
are fully guaranteed
unfortunately narratives in bosnia and
herzegovina often swing between two
tenaciously unachievable and unjust ants
centralized governance
and separatism
in their own way both are destructive
and contrary to the spirit of its
constitutional framework stemming from
the datum paris accord
the date on paris accord
agreement is not without its faults
which undoubtedly will need to be
addressed however
we should not underestimate bosnia and
herzegovina's well-established
sensitivities
and inherited intricacies
nor should it be subject to
experimentation that dangerously deviate
from dayton paris agreement's founding
principle principles this is essential
in moving bosnia and herzegovina forward
and securing its eu aspirations
the inequality of its constituent
peoples has been left unresolved for too
long
it unnecessarily created internal
political instabilities and tensions
in order to move forward bosnia and
herzegovina requires an appropriate
internet institutional power sharing
framework
based on principle of principles of
federalism
decentralization and legitimate
representation
the concept of constituent peoples
is always or often
rather often
misrepresented as an obstacle to the
equal rights of all its citizens many
political and legal practices can be
insured without having to give up
democratic rights and freedoms
bosnia and herzegovina's electoral
reforms are long overdue
and urgently needed
electoral reforms should facilitate
constituent peoples
namely bosniaks serbs and croats
are able to respectively choose their
representatives at all appropriate
political levels
bosnia and herzegovina scratch have not
been able to exercise this right
it is no wonder they feel marginalized
and disenfranchised and this should
change
mr president the collapse of
afghanistan's government is a major
setback after 20 years of our engagement
and investments
it is hard not to come away discouraged
we will certainly assess the lessons
from our afghan experience but the quick
question today is how should we deal
with a taliban
maintaining a pragmatic approach will
not be easy
as we rightfully call upon those in
power to respect the most fundamental
rights of their people
security will remain fragile as risks of
regional spillover cannot be ruled out
we are also concerned afghanistan may
once again become a breeding ground for
terrorism
croatia has decided to financially
support u.n ocean's efforts in providing
humanitarian support to the afghan
people
the middle east peace process remains
crucial not regionally but globally we
call on both sides to refrain from
unilateral actions that could ex
accelerate tensions and reopen the new
cycles of violence
in the long term the focus should be on
developing a wider political horizon
for meaningful negotiations
and renewing the peace process
a two-state solution based on
internationally agreed upon
parameters remain viable
reviving the iran nuclear deal
is a key instrument of regional security
and stability
that can still serve as a useful
platform for broader regional dialogue
we hope that further diplomatic efforts
will contribute to resolving issues of
common interest
after over a decade of instability
the libyan crisis could be winning
winding down
nevertheless a lasting peace will remain
complicated i sincerely hope the planned
elections will be held in december
as the legitimate leadership is an
important precondition for successful
trade
transition
mr president
together
we urgently need to start reforming the
u.n especially the security council
our main instrument for securing global
peace and security in this regard
we welcome the secretary general's
efforts expressed in his recently
published report
our common agenda
croatia also upholds the responsibility
to protect
consensually adopted in 2005 world
summit outcome
we welcomed the general assembly's
resolution the responsibility to protect
as the prevention
and the prevention of genocide war
crimes
ethnic lansing and crimes against
humanity adopted in this assembly with
overwhelming support together with costa
rica denmark
and the global center for responsibility
to protect croatia organized yesterday's
special event on protecting
women and girls directly affected and
often targeted in conflict and
post-conflict settings
croatia reaffirms its strong commitment
to a rules-based international order
and to uphold international law
two essential ingredients of peaceful
coexistence and cooperation among states
we support the role of the international
criminal court
and call upon those member states yet to
ratify
the rom statute
to do so
promoting the rights of women and
children confronting hate speech
calling for an abolition of the death
penalty
protecting minorities and actively
promoting
casualty recording
and the mandate on truth
justice and reparations
are among our human rights priorities at
the u.n
croatia is still searching for 1858
of its citizens that are still missing
or unaccounted for
from our 9195 homeland war
it is a lasting painful burden for the
affected families
not to mention the toll on our society's
desire to move on
that's the fate of the missing is on
that the fate of the missing is unknown
some three years later
is especially excruciating
we urge other neighboring states to
cooperate in good faith
and to respect their declared
commitments and international agreements
i confess that i cannot understand the
lack of information sharing and access
to archival leads
on the possible locations
of individual
and mass graves
so many years after the conflict
mr president
it is impossible not to recall the
horrific terrorist attacks of 9 11
20 years ago terrorism continues to be
our era's formidable security threat
on the other hand it has also ushered in
unprecedented cooperation on an
unwavering resolve to counter terrorism
cyber security is perhaps one of our
fastest growing concerns
trends appear to indicate an increasing
diversification of malicious efforts
perhaps state-sponsored
being the most worrisome
particularly upsetting incidents involve
cyber attacks targeting our critical
health infrastructures already exhausted
in the struggle with a cobit-19 pandemic
croatia is proud to have contributed to
19 u.n peacekeeping operation
we also aspire to join the un peace
building commission and continue our
engagement from previous mandates
nuclear weapons and the corresponding
technologies still loom large in the
security calculus of leading global
powers
nightmare scenarios can greatly be
avoided by sincere commitments to the
nuclear prophylactic non-proliferation
treaty a foundation for globe nuclear
global order we hope to see progress in
the mpt's review conference
but while nuclear weapons cast large
shadows
let us not lose sight of lingering
threats posed by illicit illicit small
arms and light weapons trafficking
we know this first hand from the grand
and armed conflicts and organized crime
activity in western balkans
ladies and gentlemen mr president
we will continue advocating for
effective multilateral election on
tackling illegal armed transfers and
buildups thank you
on behalf of the general assembly i wish
to thank the president of the republic
of croatia for the statement just made
and i request protocol to escort his
excellency
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of egypt to
introduce an address by the head of
state
shukran
you shall
to the 77th
76th session
of the general assembly
excellency president of the 76th session
of the general assembly i would like to
first and foremost congratulate you
and your country
on assuming the presidency of the
current session of the general assembly
of the united nations and i wish you
every success in your endeavors
i also commend
the central role
of the secretary general
through his tireless efforts to uphold
the principles of the charter
the charter has been a rule book and a
reference in international nations for
more than 75 years and it remains a hope
in establishing a rule-based
international order and a peaceful world
ladies and gentlemen
the onset of the global pandemic almost
two years ago has shown that there are
common traits for humanity
but there are other aspects that can be
shared such as challenges
no matter our level of development
it is appropriate to point out the
relevance of this year's theme
reflecting the need to build our
resilience to covet 19 and our hope in
recovery
that is why we must remove all obstacles
preventing
countries
from accessing
vaccines in a fair
and equitable manner
allow me to take this opportunity
from this high tribune to present
egypt's view of today's world and our
contribution to overcoming global
challenges
as a founding member of the united
nations and a number of regional
organizations
so that we can look at the challenges of
today's world
mr president
the egyptian state
is aware
and recognizes
gaps in economic recovery of states
depending on their ability to obtain
sufficient quantities of vaccines
indeed developed countries continue to
receive the majority of vaccines
produced globally
egypt underscores the need for a swift
and effective response
to meet the needs of the african
continent indeed our continent is that
which is most impacted by
the pandemic
while it has also continued to face
other equally daunting challenges some
that are equally dangerous
for that reason egypt has sought to
produce vaccines domestically
not only to meet the needs of our people
but also to export them
to the african continent ladies and
gentlemen
the prevailing circumstances have
further
exacerbated
difficulties that we've experienced for
decades
further weakening regional international
cooperation
and this is why
it is necessary
for the international
community to provide support to the
developing world
and to include middle income countries
these countries carry a significant
democratic weight
as they are home to a large part of the
world's population
of goods and services
and a driving force
for
world economic growth
light of the recent international
efforts to issue some 650 billion
dollars in special drawing rights at the
imf
we believe it is imperative to explore
the best means to
invest these resources for the benefit
of the developing world
and in that context
reduce the debt of developing countries
especially african countries and middle
and income
middle and low income countries
and provide preferential rates
by providing the necessary means
for concessional funding and encouraging
a direct investment
to these countries
these measures
would provide crucial support for
national development efforts
in line with relevant international and
regional development agendas
mr president we are convinced that
development must include
a comprehensive framework inclusive
of the necessary rights
for the development of individuals and
the promotion of a life of dignity for
societies accordingly egypt has adopted
a series of economic reform policies
allowing us to implement ambitious
social programs
for the benefit of the most vulnerable
groups and we have achieved the sdgs in
a number of areas across egypt egypt has
also managed to reduce disparities
between rural and urban areas
as we are convinced that the provision
of basic services
in all
parts of the country will promote
political and social inclusion
by creating
suitable conditions
for the freedom of thought
and innovation
to allow
innovation to flourish creating more
impetus for progress
mr president egypt is well aware of the
threats that environmental degradation
posed to all aspects of our life and
that of future generations
if not their survival
especially as a result of climate change
its adverse effects have become evident
to all
as demonstrated by the many severe
climate events across the world
in recent months
from floods
to heavy rainfall to unprecedented
spikes in temperature and wildfires
these events have had human economic and
social implications
which then add to the heavy burden of
states
and governments
struggling to guarantee the prosperity
and well-being of their people
given our common moral responsibility
towards future generation and in line
with our national vision and
international commitments
egypt
spares no effort for greater
coordination on climate issues
this is important if we are to avoid the
point of no return
a point
at which climate change would have
become so entrenched it would be
impossible to roll back
as an active participant in the climate
change negotiations
egypt looks forward to hosting the 27th
conference of state parties in 2022
terrorism remains one of the largest
challenges facing humanity
today
in adding
in addition to violating people's most
fundamental rights especially the right
to life this phenomenon also distracts
governments from fulfilling
their socioeconomic and cultural duties
towards their
people
egypt thus emphasizes
that terrorism can only be eliminated
by countering
the taqfiri and extremist ideologies
that lead to such a heinous phenomenon
we need a comprehensive approach that
would go beyond
security and military confrontation of
terrorists and terrorist groups but that
would also include
social economic development and
ideological factors as well
we must focus on the sources of
terrorism and tackle those factors that
push individuals towards this phenomenon
and this approach should be rooted both
in national actions and international
cooperation
in
this regard all countries must uphold
their obligations
under international law and relevant
social security
excuse me
security council resolutions corrects
the interpreter
i stress the need to hold accountable
those countries that sponsor and harbor
terrorists including foreign terrorist
fighters
by offering them shelter
and support and facilitating their
transit through territories which
threatens
international peace and security
ladies and gents and gentlemen
egypt is committed
to promoting the human rights of its
citizens
we make every effort to this end in full
respect of the principles of citizenship
and the rule of law
the egyptian state
is fully cognizant of the fact that
egyptians must be at the center of our
comprehensive development efforts
the aim of which is to guarantee the
dignity
rights and freedoms
of egyptian citizens
the situation of human rights in egypt
has recently seen marked
the rights and freedoms guaranteed by
the provisions of our constitution and
its amendments
and the relevant updated laws and
legislation
the national human rights strategy that
egypt launched a few days ago
following society-wide and civil society
consultations
showcases egypt's inclusive and
constructive approach
to all issues related to human rights
mr president egypt's
election to the chairmanship of the
current 15 session united nations
peace building commission is the
culmination of egypt's continued and
active contribution to promoting the
united nations peace building
architecture
since its inception in 2005.
this demonstrates the confidence that
the international community has in egypt
to lead international efforts in this
regard
we are the seventh largest contributor
of male and female troops and police to
un peacekeeping operations
mr president
egypt has always reiterated
that
there can be no stability in the middle
east
without a just
lasting and comprehensive solution to
the palestinian question which remains
the central cause for the arab region
this must happen
in accordance with international
resolutions to establish a palestinian
state
along the june 4th 1967 border with east
jerusalem as its capital in this regard
egypt stresses the need to consolidate
the ceasefire agreement reached on the
20th of may 2021
egypt also calls upon the international
community to take the necessary measures
to improve the living conditions of the
palestinian people
and
to ensure humanitarian deliveries to the
palestinian peoples
donors must be called upon to support
unrwa
this would pave the way
for the reconstruction of the gaza strip
egypt has also announced a pledge of 500
million dollars for reconstruction
efforts
the middle east has a strategic location
but it is also in one of the most
unstable regions in the world
this compounds
global and shared challenges this means
that there are specific challenges faced
by countries in the region
the concept of the strong and cohesive
nation state is under threat
from factors including division and
fragmentation be it sectarian political
or ethnic division
this has meant that countries rich in
natural resources history and
civilization such as iraq a brother
country
or
rich in culture and diversity like
lebanon and syria or with resources and
wealth such as libya or
with strategically important locations
such as yemen
suffer numerous challenges
this proves that there is no alternative
to the concept of the inclusive nation
states
states that do not distinguish
between its citizens and prevent any
interference in the affairs of the arab
region
mr president ladies and gentlemen egypt
is closely linked to its african context
something that we are immensely proud of
this is geographical continuity but also
existential continuity
hence the importance
of cooperation
of countries on this continent but
this must be a two-way street it cannot
be unilateral
being determined by one party to the
detriment of others egypt recognizes its
neighbors right to development but we
are a country that suffers from droughts
and people live under the water poverty
line
the nile is egypt's lifeline which
explains
the extreme anguish that egypt feel over
the renaissance dam you are probably all
aware of the current state of the
negotiations
between egypt ethiopia and sudan which
have lasted for 10 years
and an unjustified refusal to engage
positively in negotiations
in consecutive steps this is a
unilateral approach and a policy of
impositions
which
could further destabilize the region
egypt does sought the help of the united
nations security council
to send u.n observers and bolster
african mediation efforts egypt remains
committed to reaching
as soon as possible a comprehensive
balanced and legally binding agreement
on the filling and operation of the
ethiopian dam
this aims at
ensuring the survival of 150 million
people in egypt and sudan and to avoid
causing irreparable damage
to the peoples of both countries
this is based not only on the values of
equity
and logic but also
on robust international legal grounds
which call for the fair and just use
of joint water resources
in international rivers
ladies and
we are facing a great many challenges
and difficulties however multilateralism
remains our only
refuge
from escalating conflicts and disputes
given the multiplicity of challenges
facing us today we must
reflect on the best way to mobilize the
resources needed to overcome these
challenges and this is a priority
for the benefit of all of humanity
this is egypt's clarion call to all of
humanity
let us stand together
to save ourselves before it is too late
let us arm ourselves not with the logic
of force but the force of logic thank
you for your kind attention
and i wish you all a successful session
on behalf of the general assembly i wish
to thank the president of the arab
republic of egypt for the statement just
made
the assembly will hear an address by his
excellency pedro castillo terranes
president of the republic of peru
may i request protocol to escort his
excellency
on behalf of the general assembly i have
the honor to welcome to the united
nations his excellency pedro castillo
terranes
president of the republic of peru and to
invite him to address the assembly
mr president of the general assembly
mr secretary general
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
the 76th
session of the general assembly
is taking place in a world context
marked by instability and uncertainty
security economic recovery
and the decrease of inequality in
poverty
it is up to you
president to shoulder
the responsibility of leading the
general assembly at this changing and
fragile moment
i am convinced that your dexterity
knowledge and experience will lead us to
the best decisions and success in our
endeavors
coinciding with the bicentennial of
peru's independence on the 28th of july
of this year i assumed the presidency of
the republic
in a democratic exercise whereby the
sovereign will of the people
led to a vote for social change with
macroeconomic stability and sustainable
growth it is the first time in the
history of my country
that a school teacher from the rural
world
has assumed the leadership
destination of my country
i am compelled by mars
middle classes and all those who have
suffered from the pandemic without
exclusion all peruvians
the peru peru is a cradle of one of the
greatest civilizations
in the history of humanity
it is a multicultural country which is
multi-ethnic
and it has staked my government to build
a society
with roots in the people with social
inclusion that would eliminate
inequality
a society whereby freedom and civil
rights would be guaranteed by a
democratic and representative government
and state
that would drive forward the
participation of the people and
governments at the sub-national level
regional and local levels in all
processes in taking decisions
the task is not just to consolidate the
rule of law and the division of powers
but also to make effective in political
life the exercise
of the rights of the people on a
day-to-day basis
25 years ago and since the last 25 years
the economy of peru has
enjoyed sustained growth
one of the most important economies in
latin america and notwithstanding this
the
ravages of the pandemic on the national
economy and the world
will impact our responsible management
and efficient macroeconomic framework in
order to continue expanding and growing
and provide better redistribution of
income
at the same time
peru
presents indicators of inequality and
extreme exclusion a situation
which compromises the values and ethics
of a democratic society impacts the
competitiveness of the state and the
economy and that is why it's necessary
to provide social transformation that
will allow all peruvian men and women to
enjoy their social and economic rights
in addition to fundamental freedoms
civil rights and political rights a
transformation
of all
households and every family their rights
in education health care decent
employment dignified salaries social
security
access to housing and access to
individual life economics and the
collective which is respectful of the
rights of mother earth
we also endorse the historic initiative
of secretary general daniel gudesh to
build
a common agenda
in the world
in a post-pandemic world that would
establish a new social contract
you have reminded us
mr secretary general that the 10 richest
men in the world
combined wealth
increased by a half billion dollars
since the beginning of the pandemic
while we are
grappling with the worst employment
crisis since the great depression with
millions of people out of work or
underemployed
given the
unequal distribution of wealth the
secretary general is asking the world to
have a new social contract worldwide
which we fully endorse
the same diagnosis and determination of
a new social contract
is important for transformative action
and the number of infected with kovid
exceeded 220 million
in the second consecutive year of this
pandemic and this is the context against
which this general debate is taking
place
vaccines have opened the way and faith
for humanity to assume the conviction
that we will win this battle
but
combating the pandemic has shown
and demonstrated the international
system in capacity to cooperate under
principles of solidarity and efficiency
we need agreements in place that will
ensure
equitable access to vaccines and their
application multilateral cooperation is
still very much absent in fighting at
19.
the initiative of a new global agenda
should include
vigorous and urgent multilateral action
to combat the pandemic
and allow access for all countries
especially
of all countries gaining access which is
inclusive equitable and
non-discriminatory to all diagnosis
there are therapies medications and
vaccines
as well as to technology and health care
products
including their components and
precursors
as required in responding to covet 19 as
a worldwide priority
including access which is fair
we must attach
the greatest priority to strengthening
international scientific cooperation to
combat the pentagon
we must strengthen initiatives
that have been developed with this view
in mind especially
given that i want to
the signing of a world agreement between
heads of state
and the owners of patents to guarantee
universal access to the vaccine of all
inhabitants of the planet without any
privileges or discrimination
this would be a serious demonstration of
our commitment to life and health for
all peoples
mr president
it is necessary to adapt the sustainable
development
goals to the new reality of the
post-pandemic world
peru has a
foreign national policy which is
decentralized autonomous
which is geared to
solidarity and cooperation
with all
entities state entities and non-states
social diplomacy
is thus a priority for us
as it is today for the united
nations special attention to the
sustainable development goals which are
most pressing for the most needy for the
poorest
the goal of zero hunger
should focus the efforts of the
international community it is vital to
redouble our action to meet the food
needs
the immediate food needs of all
vulnerable people
it's vital to stimulate
social protection programs to maintain
and increase
world trade and food to maintain the
proper functioning of the gears
of the
national supply chains for food
and to support
small producers capacity to increase the
production of food
we are also committed
to a social development policy which
will allow peru
to meet the millennium development goals
especially with regard to access to
water
health care networks reducing poverty
eliminating
extreme poverty reducing
infant mortality
full access
to health care
guaranteeing inclusive and quality
education
gender equality especially
job creation and improving
informal employment
jobs are the only lasting antidote to
poverty healthcare education access to
water and sanitation cannot be a
business
which is a profitable one
these are fundamental human rights that
we need to guarantee ensuring universal
access which is of quality without any
discrimination
as a school teacher by profession
i must call the international attention
to the millions of boys and girls and
adolescents around the world who are not
in school who are not being education a
situation which has been worsened by the
health care crisis i am convinced
that society's capacity to overcome the
complex challenges we must grapple with
must include education
for our children
our young people
the secretary general's initiative
to agree on a new global social contract
should be reflected
given the serious impact of the pandemic
on schools and education it should be
reflected thus in an initiative to
universalize education
women and girls account for half of the
world's population they are a strong
determining force with creative capacity
labor potential economic and spiritual
potential must be unlocked for our
societies
the new global
social impact
and they should go beyond recognition
they should be effectively enjoyed at
all levels local regional national and
worldwide we must establish specific and
concrete
gender equity we must eliminate all
legal social and economic obstacles that
hinder the empowerment of women and
girls we must fully guarantee their
rights
and eliminate all
social practices and norms which are
discriminatory against women my
government will do so
peru mr president is thereby
linking its national agenda for social
development
with the priority agenda of the united
nations
with the common goal of applying
and achieving agenda 2030.
it is time
to put forward
the social component in international
relations and to commit ourselves to all
actions initiatives and resources of the
united nations being
used for the fulfillment of the
sustainable development goals
social diplomacy is not just a national
requirement it is a global imperative
mr president
human action without respect for nature
has led us to question the viability of
the planet
fighting climate change
calls into question our consciences
limiting increases of the temperature
between 1.5 and 2 degrees
which is the goal that was set forth in
the paris agreement
is a commitment in its very
viability
meanwhile desertification continues to
clear
forests especially in the amazon and the
effects of climate change are
increasingly devastating
the time has come
to rethink our activities to achieve
social
sustainable development in harmony with
the planet
with a view to bequeathing a habitable
which is carbon neutral by 2050 and
reducing
greenhouse gases
from 30 to 40 percent
thereby respecting what was projected
for 2030.
as an expression of its commitment to
the health of the planet my government
will
declare
the national climate emergency
this assembly once more will be debating
the very serious problem of terrorism
peru has suffered from violent terrorism
and has been able
to prevail
we're aware of reject and condemn
terrorism in all of its forms and we
support any action to fight it
we are committed to the global strategy
of the united nations
terrorism terrorism can never be a means
for social transformation
violence only leads to destruction
violations of human rights and victims
who are the poorest
and the most dispossessed
terrorism
is violence against human dignity and it
is not reconcilable with the values of
democratic societies
at the regional level peru is committed
to international peace and security it
is committed to the respective
international law and an inclusive
agenda mr president
i am a teacher
who is convinced that if we do not use
the governments of all the world to help
children move forward we will not have
accomplished anything
the present is fragile for world
diplomacy particularly
for multilateralism
but i believe that our collective
determination will always be stronger
and i stand convinced
that with the initiative of a new global
agenda
we can build together
a world of peace a world of friendship
of cooperation and well-being
thank you
on behalf of the general assembly i wish
to thank the president of the republic
of peru for the statement just made and
i request protocol to escort his
excellency
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of
turkmenistan to introduce an address by
the head of state
uh
a pre-recorded video statement
by his excellency mr gurban ghouli
muhammad
the president of turkmenistan
thank you mr president
esteemed mr secretary general esteemed
mr president
first of all
allow me
to congratulate mr abdullah shaheed
upon his election to the presidency of
the 76th session of the united nations
general assembly
and to wish him every success
in this position of responsibility
i would like to assure you
that
turkmenistan will lend you mr shaheed
its full assistance and support
we would also like to kindly ask mr
volcan bosque to accept our sincere
gratitude for his able and effective
work
in the position of president of the 75th
session
distinguished participants
the current state of global realities
and the nature and trends of political
economic and social processes
objectively require closer and more
coordinated cooperation among countries
and major international organizations in
order to achieve
our primary common goal
to ensure
global peace and security
the conditions for further sustainable
development and progress
and to preserve the legal and
institutional foundation
that forms the basis
of the modern world order
the degree
and global goals and priorities
or to put it another way
will we as members of the global
community show sufficient responsibility
foresight and political will
to overcome disagreements tactical
divergences and differences in
approaches and assessments
to focus on achieving strategic
long-term development
objectives
resolving the most acute global problems
such as questions of environment
energy and
the food distribution of water resources
alleviating poverty
protection from natural disasters
countering terrorism
drug related threats and other
challenges
[Music]
this fully applies to the problem of
combating this dangerous novel infection
and mitigating the socioeconomic
consequences caused by its spread
the pandemic has exposed serious
systemic failings in the international
response to this challenge
we firmly believe
that only if all un member states and un
system organizations join forces
will they be able to create the
conditions for succeeding in the fight
against this common threat
at the same time
the problem of the korean virus should
not be politicized nor should it be used
as a tool
for exerting influence in relations
between states
we underline
that the main platform for multilateral
dialogue to develop consolidated and
mutually agreed responses to common
challenges
in the field of global healthcare
is the world health organization
turkmenistan
will continue
to promote
its
previously voiced initiatives
aimed at intensifying multilateral
cooperation
in the area of science diplomacy
in particular
during the 76th session
we propose to consider instituting the
following international and regional
the instruments health organization
special program for studying the genome
of the coronavirus
the world health organization
multilateral mechanism to combat
pneumonia methadone
the world health organization
methodological center to treat and
prevent acute infections
and the central asian regional center
for epidemiology virology and
bacteriology
in the context of mitigating the
negative economic impacts of the
pandemic turkmenistan believes that the
un's activity needs to be strengthened
in certain
areas in particular
we should actively work on restoring
and strengthening the resilience of
international transport systems in the
face of emergencies
and there is a good foundation for that
namely
the un general assembly resolution
strengthening the links between all
modes of transport
to achieve stable
and reliable international transport for
sustainable development during and after
the coronavirus disease covered 19
pandemic
adopted upon the initiative of
turkmenistan
on the 29th of july 2021
distinguished participants
[Music]
this recent period has been marked by
serious problems when it comes to
ensuring global peace and security
under such circumstances turkmenistan
as a responsible member of the global
community
will continue to consistently help in
resolving international issues
exclusively through peaceful political
and diplomatic means
based on the principles and norms of the
un charter
fundamental
conventions and other international
documents
in this respect
we plan to take several practical steps
to fully realize the potential of
neutrality
as an effective instrument
for peacemaking and for reaching
constructive consensus decisions
and in so doing to implement the
provisions of the un general assembly
resolution
the role and importance of a policy of
neutrality
in maintaining and strengthening
international peace
security and sustainable development
which was adopted upon the initiative of
turkmenistan on the 7th of december
2020.
as you know this year was declared the
year of peace and trust by the un
general assembly
as a country that was behind this
decision
turkmenistan has undertaken enormous
international work aimed at
strengthening a culture of peace
and respectful dialogue
addressing the present lack of trust in
international relations
turkmenistan plans to round off the
events of this year of peace and trust
by convening
in december this year in ashgabat
an international conference
on the policy of peace and trust
as the foundation of international
security stability and development
we invite you and member states and
international organizations
to actively participate in this event
we nevertheless feel that the subject of
trust and a culture of dialogue
initiated this year
should remain the focus
of the world's attention and become a
permanent element on the un strategic
agenda
in this context
and in order to develop dialogue
mechanisms in central asia
turkmenistan proposes drafting a general
assembly resolution
entitled strengthening regional and
international cooperation aimed at
ensuring peace
stability
and sustainable development in the
central asia region
we believe
that considering
and adopting this document
will help promote the practical
implementation
of international initiatives from the
central asian countries that are
reflected in the outcome document of the
consultative meeting of the heads of
state of central asia which took place
on the 6th of august 2021 in
turkmenistan
acknowledging the interconnectedness and
inseparability of issues related to the
maintenance of peace security and
sustainable development in central asia
and the caspian basin region
turkmenistan reiterates its proposal to
create a zone
of peace trust and cooperation
in the central asia and caspian region
we consider this model to be a platform
for promoting
initiatives
aimed at strengthening multilateral
cooperation in the interests
of global peace and development
[Music]
mr president
distinguished participants
[Music]
the eyes of the world are fixed on
afghanistan
the situation there is not easy
the emerging institutions of power and
society are extremely fragile
and therefore
when interpreting and assessing the
situation in the country
we need to be extremely consistent
balanced and responsible both in words
and deeds
the realities in afghanistan have
changed and when coming up with
approaches to afghanistan all
ideological preferences
old grievances
phobias and stereotypes should be set
aside
we must instead first and foremost think
of the afghan people who are tired of
war
and turmoil and who are of course
dreaming of a peaceful and calm life
when developing relations with
afghanistan
turkmenistan
always prioritizes the principles of
friendship and good neighborliness as
well as the historical
cultural and civilizational commonality
of the peoples of these two countries
our country
has been and remains deeply interested
in the political stability and security
of afghanistan and the well-being and
unity of the fraternal afghan people
firm supporters of resolving disputes
through peaceful political and
diplomatic means and we call for the
quick normalization of the situation in
afghanistan and express the hope that
the nation-state institutions will be
able to work effectively for the benefit
of and in the interests of the entire
afghan people
for its part
turkmenistan will continue to provide
comprehensive economic and humanitarian
assistance to afghanistan
we are also committed
to finalizing ongoing projects and
implementing new infrastructure projects
in the areas of energy
transport and communications with afghan
participation
we see this as an important condition
for economic and social recovery in
afghanistan and its
equal and mutually beneficial
integration into global economic
relations
turkmenistan also remains ready
as a neighboring state and a neutral
state to promote the establishment of
the necessary contacts and
to help create the conditions
for the restoration of peace harmony and
unity in afghanistan
distinguished
participants during this session
turkmenistan
looks forward to continuing a broad
dialogue on achieving these sustainable
development goals
in our view
the main priority
is effective collaboration
and the practical compatibility of the
global regional and national instruments
being used to implement the sdgs
we call for the active promotion
of
adequate financing
for the 2030 agenda for sustainable
development
in this regard
we believe that it is necessary to
organize another international
conference on
financing for development as soon as
possible
we will continue to pay attention to and
draw the attention of the global
community to the issue of mitigating the
consequences of an environmental and
ecological disaster in the aral sea
during the upcoming session turkmenistan
together with its partners in the region
intends to
pursue the creation of a un special
programme for the rlc basin
the humanitarian issue remains among
our priorities when it comes to
turkmenistan's agenda for cooperation
with the u.n
as a member of the un commission for
social development
2021-2025 turkmenistan intends to
strengthen its role as the main
coordinating body
for developing coordinated approaches
and actions to global issues of social
protection
youth affairs
strengthening the role of the
traditional family
migration policy will continue to be
an important area of cooperation between
turkmenistan and the u.n
as a permanent member of the executive
committee of the programme of the high
commissioner for refugees and
having extensive experience in dealing
with such complex humanitarian
situations turkmenistan stands ready to
make its contribution to solving these
global issues
distinguished participants
we are united by common thoughts and
hopes
worries and threats
this makes the experience gained in
solving complex problems jointly whether
it is on an international scale or at
the regional and national levels
all the more valuable
turkmenistan stands ready to share that
experience
and together with partners to pursue new
approaches and ways to overcome the
challenges facing the united nations
we declare our firm commitment to
cooperating with the united nations
actively participating
in and contributing to its political and
diplomatic efforts to preserve and
strengthen the existing architecture of
global security
overcome the consequences of the
pandemic
and to implement plans and programs in
the economic social
environmental humanitarian and other
fields
turkmenistan's partnership with the
united nations
and remains
a strategic priority
and an ideological
and practical foundation
for
all our activities
in the international arena
thank you for your attention
on behalf of the general assembly i wish
to thank the president of turkmenistan
for the statement just made
the assembly will now hear an address by
his excellency saulinisto
president of the republic of finland
may i request protocol to escort his
excellency
on behalf of the general assembly i have
the honor to welcome to the united
nations his excellency sauli ninisto
president of the republic of finland and
to invite him to address the assembly
mr president
secretary general
distinguished delegates
ladies and gentlemen
at the outset i would like to
congratulate mr
abdullah shahid
for his election as the president of the
76th
session of the general assembly
i also want to congratulate mr antonio
gutierrez
for the re-election for his second term
as secretary general
both of you
can
count on finland's full support
for your important work
finland warmly welcomes the ambitious
approach put forward in the secretary
general's our common agenda
it is easy to agree with one of the key
statements
in that document
in our biggest shared test since the
second world war
humanity
faces a stark and urgent choice
a breakdown
or
a breakthrough
we are indeed at a critical juncture if
humanity is to make the right choice
a breakthrough rather than a break down
we have to shoulder our human
responsibilities
responsibilities for our common future
the task may seem daunting
the past years have witnessed
continued and even growing turbulence in
the world
volatility and uncertainty
may easily lead to despair
common solutions may seem far out of
reach
at the same time many trends highlight
how
interconnected our world is
the pandemic has had an impact on every
one of us
the same will increasingly be true of
climate change and emerging technologies
alike
conflicts no longer remain local or
regional they have consequences direct
or indirect across the globe
all of these cross-border challenges are
crying for a global response
with a high mindset such a response is
within reach
in 1975 30 years after the united
nations was founded
35 heads of states and governments
gathered in the finnish capital to sign
the helsinki final act
the letter of that document still valid
today focused on security and
cooperation in europe
but the spirit
that arose from that meeting
can have a more global significance
if we succeed in reviving and expanding
it
a willingness of adversaries and
competitors to engage in dialogue to
build trust and to seek common
denominators
that was the essence of the helsinki
spirit
its potential today is by no means
limited to the osce area
it is precisely that kind of spirit that
the entire world and the united nations
urgently needs
i'm convinced that the more we speak
about the helsinki spirit the closer we
get
to rekindling it
and to making it come true
and that will bring us closer to solving
our common challenges together
ladies and gentlemen
over a year and a half since its
beginning we still live in the shadow of
the kobit 19 pandemic
fortunately
there is now some light at the end of
the tunnel in many countries
yet we should
resist the temptation to think about
health security on a national basis
alone
the scientific community has shown a
better example than governments
to end this pandemic the solution has to
be global
for a global response to succeed we need
to ensure equitable access to effective
remedies
looking through
finland is strongly committed to vaccine
solidarity
global action is also needed in order to
be better prepared for future pandemics
it is high time to take concrete steps
to improve our common health security
beyond the current challenges
to improve our resilience
we need a one health approach
enhancing international
collaboration on research and
development
and
exchanging information on emerging
threats
is
vital we must ensure
the effective functioning of the
multilateral global health institutions
such as the world health
organization
we must also take pause to reflect upon
the long-term
ramifications of kobe 19.
it has led to an increase in extreme
poverty and inequality
and resulted
in a
deterioration of gender equality
it has seriously affected many countries
ability to reach the sustainable
development goals
we must
intensify
our efforts to ensure that the most
vulnerable are not left further behind
mr president
the pandemic has shown that a severe
enough concern can push us to take
unprecedented
steps
in a very short order we all have taken
more extreme measures to change our
behavior
than any one of us could have imagined
before
what would be a sufficient wake-up call
for us to do the same for the health of
our planet
with a 2030 agenda
the paris climate agreement and the
convention on biological diversity
we already have plenty of documents and
roadmaps to rely on
but talk is not enough
we need to act and the time for action
is now
the rapidly proceeding loss of
biodiversity alone
should be a cause for immediate global
concern
in addition we now know that climate
change is proceeding even faster
than was previously thought
according to the ipcc we are likely to
reach the 1.5 degrees temperature rise
already in the early 2030s
it's not an exaggeration to say that we
are facing a global climate emergency
and yet that urgency is still not
reflected in our deeds
the national determined
contributions we
the signatures of the paris agreement
have made so far
may still put us on a track of a 2.7
degree temperature rise by the end of
this century
the consequences for the planet and for
future generations would be catastrophic
we have to use
the upcoming cop
26 conference
to put ourselves on a sustainable course
it's our common responsibility
that of
governments and institutions of
companies
and individuals
to step up
we need more ambitious emission
reduction plans
well ahead of the meeting in glasgow
and we must speed
up the ongoing transition away from
fossil fuels
to succeed
we need adequate climate financing as a
global community we have to increase the
quality quantity
and
accessibility of climate finance
in particular
to the
least developed countries and a small
island developing countries
we must also encourage finance ministers
to take climate change in account in all
of their decision-making
the coalition of finance ministers for
climate action
co-chaired by finland and indonesia
has already more than
60 members
it currently focuses on green recovery
carbon pricing and biodiversity
we invite more countries to join the
work of this coalition
mr president
the dramatic events of afghanistan in
the past weeks have again reminded us
of the fragility of peace and security
the humanitarian needs in afghanistan
are immense
and it is critical that we act together
to ensure
the access of humanitarian assistance to
its people
the un
organizations staying on the in
afghanistan play a key role here
and the international community must be
steadfast on this
women and girls in afghanistan must not
be forgotten or made invisible
yet unfortunately afghanistan is just
one example
conflicts old and new ones
continue to cause human suffering across
the world
the diplomatic toolbox of the charter
needs to be used to its full potential
to build peace where needed and to
prevent conflicts
where possible
for finland conflict prevention and
mediation
are strong priorities
we continue to be ready and willing to
offer our good services for constructive
dialogue in this regard
mr president
in its foreign policy finland has long
underscored the importance of the
universal and binding nature of human
rights
our own experience
is that a society flourishes
when everyone has an active equal and
meaningful role in it
finland is a candidate to the u.n human
rights council for the period from 2022
to 2024
as a member of the council
we will do our best to make our human
rights priorities work for the benefit
of peace stability and prosperity
across the world
in our human rights policy we pay
special attention to the rights of those
in most vulnerable situations
the ones most exposed to discrimination
promoting the rights of persons with
disabilities
and a cross-cutting priority for finland
another key theme for us
are the rights of all women and girls
the recently launched generation
equality campaign
in which finland co-leads the action
coalition and technology and innovation
has an important role in mobilizing
different actors for gender equality
mr president
in an era of intensifying great power
competition and rapid technological
progress
we are also faced with a serious risk of
a new arms race
in the unrebelling of the international
arms control system
is allowed to continue
it reduces predictability and increases
the likelihood of you
unintended escalation
that will make all of us less secure
we urgently need to
remedy the situation
the most important task is to uphold and
strengthen
the existing arms control architecture
but at the same time we also need to
think ahead with an open mind
we have to develop new solutions to
respond to emerging challenges and
technologies
by strengthening
confidence building
verification
and transparency
in nuclear arms control finland welcomes
the extension of new start
yet
yet it is also clear
that engagement between all the nuclear
powers would be beneficial for global
security
mr president
the need to come together and to save
the planet for the future generations
has rarely been created
for finland
the un system is at the core of the
rules-based order we want to defend
and the multilateralism we want to
strengthen
no other organization has the same
legitimacy or the same normative impact
no other organization gives hope to so
many people for a better world
no other organization can deliver the
future we want
and the future we deserve
but the united nations can only succeed
if we
its members want to come together and do
what is needed and expected from us
that requires more dialogue
that requires more trust
that requires more helsinki spirit
from all of us
in this spirit finland continues its
unwavering support for the united
nations
thank you
[Applause]
on behalf of the general assembly i wish
to thank the president of the republic
of finland for the statement just made
and may i request protocol to escort his
excellency
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of the
philippines to introduce and address by
the head of state
excellencies i have the honor to
introduce the president of the republic
of the philippines his excellency mr
rodrigo roha duterte
mr president
i congratulate you on your election
and welcome your presidency of hope
indeed that is what we need in these
challenging times
for nearly two years now
the pandemic has ended our lives
the climate crisis has worse and
the
inequalities have deepened
and the geopolitical balance
is in a state of dangerous flocks
certainly
these are complex problems
but one thing is clear
they all hit the poor
the hardest
injustice is the common thread
that ties these issues together
when i spoke before this august body
last year
i said
that how we address these issues
will define our future
from what i have seen
that future will likely be one of
inequality
for the poor
place catch up with rich
with no hope or chance of ever
succeeding
in closing the gap
we cannot in all conscience
allow this to happen
an unjust order
is inherently
volatile
we have to reverse
course
how then do we
as governments reconcile our obligations
their own citizens without
responsibility
to the rest of humanity
for the philippines we understand
that we need to expand our notion
of us
beyond the nation so we can work
together to secure our common future
we recognize that only inclusive
multilateralism
can deliver the global public goods we
need
and we believe that fairness equality
and respect
should always be the basis of our
engagement with one another
only with this can we correct the
injustices
that doomed the downtrodden
all over the world
to a life of indignity
and for the thousands during this
pandemic
certain death
mr president the picture is bleak
it is a man-made drought of vaccines
ravaging the poor countries
rich countries hold life-saving vaccines
when poor nations wait for trickles
they now talk of booster shots
where developing countries consider
half doses just to get by
this is shocking beyond belief
and must be condemned for what it is
a selfish act that can either be
justified
rationally
or morally
the plain fact is
this pandemic will not end
unless the virus is defeated everywhere
vaccines are key to achieving this
this is why the philippines committed
one million dollars
to the unscovux facility
this is our modest contribution to our
collective fight against kovid
19.
we strongly urge our privileged partners
to fully support the kovacs facility
and further strengthened
other cooperation mechanisms
we need this to save more lives break
the cycle of variance and help
ensure global economic recovery
just as kobe 19 has had an uneven impact
on the people's
climate change has also exposed the
varying vulnerabilities
of countries around the globe
the risks and burden of a warming
climate are simply not the same for
everyone
the greatest injustice here is that
those who suffer the most
are those the least responsible for this
existential crisis
but here we are now
at a critical tipping point
where failure to act leads to
cataclysmic consequences for the rule of
humankind
the philippines accept its share of
responsibility
and will do its part to avert this
collective disaster
we submitted our first nationally
determined contribution
with the target to reduce greenhouse gas
emission by 75
by 2030
i issued a moratorium on the
construction of new coal power plants
and a directive to explore the nuclear
energy
option
but this contribution will be rendered
useless
if the biggest polluters past and
present choose to do business as usual
we therefore appeal for urgent climate
actions especially those
who can truly tip the balance
developed countries must fulfill their
long-standing commitment to climate
financing technology transfer and
capacity building in the developing
world
this
is a moral obligation that cannot be
avoided
a worse transition
to green economy
must not be at the expense of developing
countries
economic vitality
it simply cannot be
or it would be another travesty of
justice mr president the filipino people
aspire
for stable comfortable and secure life
founded on freedom
justice and equality
we have made significant strides on this
after more than a century of nation
building
today
the philippines is a middle-income
economy and a driving democracy
but difficult challenges remain
this we do not deny
millions of filipinos work abroad
under the most difficult and inhumane
of circumstances
we call for the abolition of all
structures
that allow exploitations and oppression
of migrant workers
the kafala system is one such payment
the change
the weak
the desperate and the voiceless
to an existence of unimaginable
suffering
nothing can justify the continued
existence of this unjust system
while reforms have been made
the kafala system must be dismantled
sooner or later in the name of justice
and basic decency
philippines seeks stronger partnerships
to protect the rights of the filipinos
and realize the full potential of our
nation
but let me be clear
what we mean is partnership that
respects our people's
agency
let me say this again
my government has a mandate
an obligation to my people
we will deal with all criminals
including terrorists
with the full force
overalls
the filipino people want to live in
peace security in their homes and
communities
free from harm
and danger from the lowness
but achieving this goal
has not been without challenges
i see this in no uncertain terms
the law applies to all
i have instructed the department of
justice and the philippine national
police
to review the conduct of our campaign
against illegal drugs
those found have acted beyond bounds
during operations shall be made
accountable before our law
we have recently finalized the united
nations
our joint program of human rights
this is a model for constructive
engagement
between a sovereign
member state
and the united nations
meaningful change to be enduring
must come from within
the imposition of one's will over
another
no matter how noble the intent
has never worked in the past and it
never will be in the future
how many more countries
shall be made to unravel
and descend into chaos
before the powerful heed the simple
lesson
in dealing with complex problems in
nation building
let us consider pragmatic approaches
that square ideals with reality
sure
they may lead us to imperfect solutions
but solutions nonetheless that actually
work
we will pay the price for a misadventure
of the few
that spiral into
humanitarian disasters
the philippines in line with its
long-standing humanitarian tradition
has opened its doors to afghan nationals
especially women and children leading
the country
as a global community we must do our
utmost to help
the afghan people and all those
who continue to suffer
for the rohingyas i have instructed our
department of justice to work closely
with the u.n high commissioner on
refugees
to prepare a cooperation program for a
specific number of virginias
consistent
with our capacities
the philippines has limited resources
during these extraordinary times
but what we can do for humanity
and will uplift human dignity we will
mr president
in a period of profound geopolitical
change
it is vital that all countries big and
small commit to the rule of law
fully and firmly
for the world without law is a world of
disaster
for the weak is at the mercy of the
strong
there can therefore be no other
acceptable basis
for a global order but the
law
we must resolve disputes peacefully
as we manifested in the manila
declaration of peaceful settlement of
international disputes
the philippines is one with the asean
and other stakeholders
in ensuring that the south china sea
remains a sea of peace security and
prosperity
the 1982 enclaves
and the 2016 orbital award
of the south china sea
provide a clear path
towards a just fair and win-win solution
for all
the award must be seen
for what it is
a benefit across the world to all who
subscribe to the majesty of the law
no amount of waterful disregard by any
country however big and powerful
can diminish the arbitrage awards
importance
mr president
we face multiple crises that demand
effective global governance
yet our institutions
including the united nations
have proven to be inadequate
the un is a product of an era long past
it no longer reflects the political
and economic realities of the world
democracy and transparency
are concepts that reverberate
in the horse of the un
but ironically
the security council
the pentacle of u.n structure
violates every tenet of these values
it is neither democratic
nor transparent in its presentation and
processes
many member states have spoken firmly
and we agree
this simply is not right
if the u.n
is to lead the world out of the many
crisis we face
things need to change
the u.n must empower itself by reforming
itself
therein
lies the hope of humanity
thank you
[Music]
on behalf of the general assembly i wish
to thank the president of the republic
of the philippines
for the statement just made
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of rwanda
to enter
to introduce an address
by the head of state
mr president
it is my distinct honor to introduce a
pre-recorded statement by his excellency
mr paul kagame president of the republic
of rwanda on the occasion of the general
debate of the 76th session
of the un general assembly thank you
excellency abdullah
shahid president
of the general assembly
excellency secretary general antonio
guterres
excellencies heads of state and
government distinguished
delegates
fighting their coveted 19 pandemic has
challenged the international system
like never before
however
alongside unfortunate examples of
inequality
we have also seen evidence of the spirit
of global solidarity and fairness
exemplifying the best values
of organization
the kovacs mechanism despite its
limitations
is one such case
without this system
africa's vaccine deficit
would be even more severe but we can and
must do more
to speed up
vaccine distribution
in africa
doing so benefits the entire world
the positive steps from
various partners and companies toward
building local vaccine manufacturing